we were talking too like
how disappointing it had to be you were
supposed to go out on the road with russ
you're on russ's album
um you know shout out to russ for just
giving so much free game and
and i think shout out to the big dog
russ man russ a great dude but like uh
how did that happen like russ and benny
on a record
when that track listing dropped i was
like i want to listen to that song what
are some of the wrong song
you know what i'm saying but like wait
like obviously you respect you as an mc
and russ
doesn't get enough love for his
capability as an emcee as well
he don't we listen we actually got a
record i don't know when he gonna drop
this record
[ __ ] russ
benny and black dog
and it's just gone we just and we both
like we are rapping long
wow what i'm saying it's almost like a
five six minute song
wow everybody's rapping long it's a
crazy song
wow i feel like it's gonna be a moment
when it come out
damn that's crazy yeah people see he
just tapping with you on dm because he's
obviously a fan of your [ __ ]
yeah yeah you know what i'm saying just
tapping me on the dm like russ don't get
enough credit for like
his lyrical abilities for sure the guy
can do anything exactly so and he gives
free game to everybody
so no matter where hit the career path
no matter what no matter where that took
him he still
got the uh ability that he got so he
could notice it in others you feel what
i'm saying so
a person don't got to be all big and
nothing like that he just reaching out
for the sport of it like i like this
dude yeah we should work so
shout out to russ cause i love when
[ __ ] do that and
help [ __ ] with opportunities and i do
the same thing i'm saying i reach back
too